he's the chief certified broadcast
meteorologist to the weather Jim Jim
Cantore busy man today who you can hear
the winds howling out there hey Jim
dan it was a rough one it was a rough
one but you know what they say March
comes in like a pride of lions it sure
has recapped last night oh my goodness
so it's snowing like white mud I mean
just Frankie Frankie Frankie piling up
all over the place on the roads and I
just tell everybody on the air I said
look you know once we get interesting
with this kind of snow once we get four
or five inches here goes the power all
right sure enough where we got about a
million customers without power some Dan
that would love to be listening to your
show right now unless they have
batteries no in their radio they're in
their cars and doing that they're in
their cars right now Lauren or they're
in their cars they came just out of
their house into their cars into that
show was there Thunder snow last night
there was all around me of course knew
your five states that thunders no
yesterday no explain thunders no all
right so thunderstorms happen in the
summer we're used to that we see that a
lot you see the lightning thunder it's a
little bit more dynamic the same
ingredients going rapidly rising in our
motion difference in charge builds up in
the cloud and boom boom boom it can
happen in the winter - it just all
happens above the cold air at the
surface does that make sense
sure could be snowing if the atmosphere
is right but you have the same physics
going on to create thunderstorm what do
you really think of those guys who and
women who aren't meteorologists they do
the weather what do you think of them
well some of them are pretty hot dan to
be honest with you beautiful these are
the beautiful people in the world and
you know we have to pay them the respect
that they deserve
how would you do though if you did local
weather I don't that's a great question
because I'm often thought you know
Nationals great I always got something
going on the problem I would have
imagined me in San Diego if I didn't
have something to geek out at or if I
didn't have a snow bank to roll on I
have to try to have some trouble I
really would I'd probably be I probably
you know wine
been in a few times yesterday I think
you would need to have a cooler name if
you did local weather and we came up
with one
Jimmy sleet seriously yeah he was got
the best name that should be doing
weather is stormy warrant from Siri sex
I mean help her
stormy doesn't [ __ ] warn new country
to see a country music oh yeah yeah okay
yeah I'm serious XM that's right yeah
but that was ranges pretty that's a
pretty good name and storm field now
it's raining at Dallas Raines is great
storm field yeah see those are all those
are all great names you're right and
let's bring in Juno so no one Jimmy
sleep joins us now with the local
weather hey Jimmy well Dan we've got a
pretty high probability of thunder snow
this afternoon and thunder sleep there's
the thing as thunder sleet and even
under freezing rain you love them get it
all you love those words you love okay
we we have a best roll off the tongue we
have a bed here now here's the bet okay
what do you got we thought Seaton said
five and a half inches would be the
snowfall in Milford Connecticut or less
the over-under is five and a half so he
said he would take the under McLovin was
taking the over and the loser has to
stand outside in the final hour of the
show and get peppered with snowballs you
are going to be the person who decides
who gets the firing squad of snowballs
this is the official total for Milford
Connecticut from the man known as Jimmy
sleet Jim Cantore certified
meteorologist and your announcement is
are you ready yeah you guys all sitting
down yeah everybody take a deep breath
here we go here we go the total was the
snowball
well Seaton is upset see all right go
that's about seven and a half inches
outside of my door how do you how how
does this the total total was measured
at seven point six inches now here's the
deal because of the weight and the
wetness of the snow it is already
compacted to probably about three inches
oh but the official snow total yeah
eleven point six yeah I think you got to
helmet get your goggles enjoy the
peloton yes no mud yeah that's what he
did that's snow mud you're right that's
shrinkage actually seven on your next
live shot on the Weather Channel could
you just say hey by the way the official
snowfall in milford connecticut seven
point six inches in lyon saying three
was seven for a long time yeah the
official the official shot of next shot
on the weather channel is going to be
tomorrow morning at the studio dan oh
yeah a little time in our own bed
believe it or not we could actually have
another nor'easter on Monday seriously
man nice
wait where's nor'easter we're right
right where you're broadcasting from
right now alright if you're backup for
the nor'easter we would like to do a
simulcast on my show in the Weather
Channel well we're out there with you
doing the live shot done okay let's do
it
well what will line up the push-up
contest we'll get the snowball fights
going I mean everything I'm gonna have
you what push-ups you do push-ups while
I do the Weather Channel the the live
weather channel update all right you got
it you got a deal all right safe travels
and great to talk to you again his name
is Jimmy sleet he's Jim Cantore the
weather channel for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
you